our national politics may seem
increasingly divisive but it's a
different story on the local level for
more than four years journalists James
and Deborah fallows traveled the country
and single-engine prop plane to learn
from Americans in smaller communities
the married duo visited places like
Allentown Pennsylvania Columbus
Mississippi Dodge City Kansas and Bend
Oregon in each place they met people
coming together to create jobs and solve
problems they Chronicle the experience
in their new book our towns a 100
thousand mile journey into the heart of
America James and Deborah fallows also
write for the Atlantic good morning to
both of you were so glad you could be
here this is a journalists dream to have
a fishing license to just go out into
the country so Jim what was the fishing
license at first what did you set out to
at first we just wanted to find out what
was going on around the country we've
been living in China for a number of
years and while they are we've gotten on
buses on the ox carts on trains to go
into the interior we thought what would
it be like to do that in this country
especially number one after the Great
Recession to see how people were
recovering and number two we had over
the years been to a number of these
places in our little propeller plane and
there are places you can get to that way
including that I own the airport in
Toronto where we've landed but they're
places you can get to in the Dakotas in
Hawaii etcetera so we thought let's see
what's out there
one thing I love by the way in the book
are the asides about flying which is a
great substrate but Deb tell me about
what surprised you the most in this
series of visits you know one of the
things that surprised me most actually
is the public libraries in all of the
small towns we went to mostly you
remember as a kid going in there to to
borrow books and read books but
libraries today have become something so
much more their social centers their
educational centers their technology
centers teaching people how to use
computers being the host for young
startup companies to get their
businesses going they are education is
primary for little kids and and literacy
programs for adults on the other end the
same thing the social and civic life
from teaching giving citizenship courses
are teaching ESL courses are doing yoga
or
or the tango and Jim this is you
developed an argument basically over the
course of these visits about what works
this isn't just oh these are nice
stories you you have a sense of what
works in these places and it's working a
lot better than in Washington yes we
have a sort of high level national
politics type argument and then a
practical city-by-city argument the high
level argument is at just the time when
we all know everything that's wrong with
the country and its national politics
and the real challenges the country has
from opioids to economic dislocation
city by city most people think they're
moving forward rather than backwards on
those issues and then we have certain
increasing patterns we saw of what made
that work one of those where I changed
my mind was the idea of a public-private
partnership which seemed to me just this
kind of slogan you'd hear a political
speech actually means something specific
in terms of schools or bridges or
orphanages or things that make these
cities better in fact you talked about
one former mayor Michael Coleman right
from Columbus Ohio and he convinced his
constituents that despite tough times
for a tax increase how did he do that
well this was right in the teeth of the
2008-2009 new depression which was as
hard in Columbus Ohio as any place and
the mayor had the choice does he layoff
very significant numbers of police
firefighters teachers etcetera or does
he ask his people to tax themselves when
they're losing their jobs to keep these
services going and they voted for the
tax increase in the city he's now one
that's just doing very well and one
other thing just as we've seen the
country change in terms of the loss of
manufacturing and mining jobs how what
did you find in these days about how
people are innovating we found a lot
especially with the Millennials give or
take a few years we're going back to
these towns and saying we want to be
here and we're going to take it upon
ourselves to start new companies to
start new endeavors and the one of the
interesting things also is that the
founding fathers in those towns said
these kids are what's going to make our
towns strong so we'll work with them
we'll lend them money we'll get them
going in places where they can do it
what I also loved was the question you
asked was who's who makes this town go
who is crucial to this town and that
that was a key to knowing whether a town
was going to be successful or not and
and who is crucial can
take all kinds of forms sometimes it's
the mayor sometimes it's the town
historian sometimes it's the musician in
town or a group of teachers in San
Bernardino it was the San Bernardino
generation now the Millennials who
started out as artists became kind of
Pied Pipers around town picking up trash
painting murals and ended up going into
the schools to educate the kids about
voting let's talk about the opioid
epidemic which is devastating this
country what did you find out when you
visited some of these communities can
they do it on their own or they need
help from the federal go so so number
one this is genuinely the worst social
problem US has right now we were seeing
early on we were up in places like by
Burlington Vermont which was exposed
this earlier than most others I think
this is a classic illustration where
local efforts can make a difference but
this is one of many fields where if we
had a more functional national
government that would be good too
because national programs make a big
difference but we found a number of sort
of city-by-city attempts to deal with it
but it's a genuine challenge are you
gonna keep doing this yes I didn't know
you were a pilot so that helps right
that helps getting to a lot of these
places
yeah I mean there's places you can get
to more easily by small plane than you
can by interstate and certainly by
commercial airlines and then another
great thing I love is the description of
the country from above because it's not
jumbo jet height right here you know the
changing landscape of the country it's
you know there's when when when flying
was becoming popular a century ago the
idea was that writers would want to be
pilots that all would want to because
you see the world students so uniquely
from 2,000 feet an airliner is too high
the road is too low but 2,000 feet you
can see the logic of the geography as it
comes together and the Norman Rockwell C
yeah such a great book thank you very
much thank you thank you we'll needs an
Deborah Fowler's we appreciate it
our towns goes on sale tomorrow